voilà ce que nous pouvions dire sur
l'aspect santé de cette éclipse totale
de soleil et beaucoup moins
scientifiques sont les prédictions des
uns et des autres sur ce qui va se
passer demain
personne n'ignore plus que le couturier
paco rabanne a prévu que la station mir
tombera sur paris et que le département
du gers sera lui aussi touché par ce
qu'il appelle le feu du ciel dans le
gers justement on prend cette prévision
avec philosophie et la certain humour
reportage à auch de stéphane du bain et
parce qu'elle va renier un tremblement
d'enfer les débris de la station et
s'écrase au fus rocher sa cathédrale
paco rabanne a calculé que les gersois
vivaient leurs dernières secondes de vie
pour eux c'est l'heure de la faco lipsky
a sonné ce soir donc ils ont décidé d'en
profiter et surtout de s'amuser puisque
ces débris de la station mieux
représentée par les députés assiette en
aluminium
et si l'antenne parabolique l'elysée
mais embarrassant de terrassement aussi
détruire c'est trop bien où l'on pense
ce sous vide par la bande dessinée ce
soir une soirée sur le thème d'astérix
et la menace est aussi notre nostra
knicks qui a chassé son élève paco
rabanne x qui était en fait un domaine
de deuxième zone
l'office du tourisme or à l aps à 15,150
nostradamus lui même a enseigné à auch
bien avant les prédictions de paco
rabanne paco rabanne il nomme après
avoir fait de la haute couture puis de
leurs hôtes soudure bas il a essayé de
se trouver un nouveau qu'il en est et
par conséquent il a fait un salmigondis
en l'an 2000
nostradamus la station mir et tout ça et
blanc et même si les gersois savent que
c'est dans leur département que l'on vit
le plus vieux en france nombreux sont
ceux qui auront dès ce soir les yeux
levés vers le ciel sans aucune
inquiétude et en s'étonnant encore du
bon coup de pub que paco rabanne leur a
fait